virtually every day now there are pramas
rallies all over the city and they take
over Grand Central and they take over
Penn Station and they go for the
Rockefeller Christmas tree and they have
protest outside Fox News and everywhere
else uh just yesterday there were
massive protests yesterday here are pro
pramas demonstrators calling for antifa
revolution outside Grand Central
terminal and down in the West
Village re only there is
onlyu the retion for the reolution there
is only one solution there is only one
solution
[Music]
re the NYPD the KKK and the IDF are all
the same I mean these people you get it
the these are brainwashed pawns they are
tools they are being used by powers that
they cannot even imagine they have no
idea you you probably saw the queer is
for pales people like these it's all
completely insane but they just take
over city streets and they take over
there's plenty of video you can find it
we're we're not showing you all of it
but they plenty of video of just going
into stores and stopping Commerce people
cannot function cities cannot function
and it really although we've said it
many many times like nobody's coming to
save New York it it is it's just
impossible you think Eric Adams is going
to save New York who's coming who's
coming it's just going to keep getting
worse check out what was happening uh in
Penn Station last
night
Allah
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah sorry folks that's not London
that's not
Paris that's not uh
belua that's New York City and again you
putting aside religion for well not not
putting aside religion if these were
Christian nationalists do you think the
mainstream media might be going crazy
but when you see that people praying
intifa Revolution R River to the Sea how
can a society function like that what if
you were just from let's say you're in
Jersey you're now you're you you took
your kids uh into the city you wanted to
go see what's on Broadway these days
Barby what's what's playing on Broadway
they got Jersey Boys still going I don't
know you take them to see J you you live
in Jersey you go to New York City to see
Jersey Boys now you're in Penn Station
trying to get uh over onto the New
Jersey Transit uh to get back to and
then you have all of these people
calling for genocide uh praying all this
stuff like a city cannot function over
time